trust nothing  this movie is for young people it's a  slice of sweetness for them in these  kind of dark times they should love  neverending stories to love escape from  which mountain I want it to be  telepathic and fly like that's what I  wanted so when I see storm read and I'm  directing her to fly and to fight the  darkness and save the universe it's like  nothing better  your father has accomplished something  extraordinary I think it'll be great to  see a little girl at the center of a big  action-adventure movie I didn't grow up  seeing that on film and I think that  would have really inspired me that  anything is possible  you're kidding do I look like I'm  kidding a little I've got I love that it  reflects the world that we live in you  know it's such a diverse cast of  powerful women and men and that it's  time we saw this reflection in big  studio movies  I just do  [Music]